hi I'm Jason schwartzmann here for the
part of Thor
I am Thor I am the god of thunder return
to me my enchanted hammer does this have
a have a sakkath that means this is
hammer have a sec just cuz it's too
heavy for my wrist right now but I want
to still keep it in the shot but I don't
have to hold it no key such a dick
ready
Loki you're such a dick
is this sweatshop free this feels funky
like it feels feels foreign return to me
my enchanted hammer Iron Man Captain
America Hulk I'd like to nominate a new
member of the Avengers noted linguist
and philosopher
no I'm Chomsky I'll dye my hair for it
by the way I don't mind I have a great
colorist I told you Loki this helmets
actually too heavy I can't lift my neck
of course I can bulk up for the part I
mean I'll do whatever I have to do I'll
eat a lot of chicken breasts or
something do you think I have to take
off my shirt for it for real where are
all the blood oranges see I have a
question is this Wake horse hair because
if it is I'm allergic it is okay I'm
gonna need you to call my allergist for
my internist it's in my phone return to
me my enchanted hammer
[Music]
all right so I'll go back to the lobster
thing okay
the lobster pick it out of the wonderful